hello and welcome to this video
Peregrine 64 this is a guy i recently
blundered something against the full
exchange or look it was in some we
exchange now not do that again i also
should look at some new line down in
this this here the line that I plane is
not particularly bad but it's also not
so challenging and there are more
challenging ways to play okay I'm trying
something else there I normally play
with an early seat xt5 but term playing
like this is a little bit more
interesting a six is uncommon they
normally go queen 85 them
important idea man ok I can go yeah I
guess night be three yeah it just might
be three is easy okay so taking that
pawn is probably not a good idea c5 he
just moves the queen that doesn't make
any sense if he takes it light a four
wins apiece so unsure and I should take
care hmm maybe maybe waiting a move
would have been best to be honest
and okay i don't know that i have to
play there should be six the spot
various me for possible g4 but maybe
this is good actually 495 hmm yeah okay
might be good
now I have to definitely go out of that
C file okay I can also go to d3 is that
better I don't know now let's go here I
got to pay out bishops but his he's got
decent activity 94 mmm oh wow what am i
doing against this guy I'm blundering
stuff left and right against him oh my
god ah just castles white is better for
every em but yeah that's not a trick
that I cannot fall into
okay i will continue I mean last time I
plunder the piece and still draw still
drew maybe you can even play night after
year and completely kill me yeah it's
possible
now what's annoying is I can just castle
in this position and I have the two
bishops and the better pawn structure
it's just eternally better for white and
nothing nothing will happen I mean it's
not it's not terribly bad phone which is
that I can play that position forever
and I'm just better instead I blunder
whole piece for that simple tactic and
now you tries to figure out if you can
take on F to do it ok I don't like to
simplify the position but I get a pawn
and I possible route e7 it's just very
slightly uncoordinated him
Queen a five probably I have to
unfortunately and my own back rank is
also terribly weak I cannot take on b7
probably because of due to that very
unfortunate the ones i mean i'm not
claiming i have any chances but at least
you have hope
well last time I drew a true a piece
down I have my doubts that I can do it
this time it looks a bit too simple
okay would you sound so some kind of a
threat yeah or not really he has ripped
g6 I guess he could just push the porn
lace is again making life difficult for
him
check it's not even that easy I mean of
course you should win but it's um check
time morning check check check ok check
so I drew that I piece down draw our
third game dry yeah dad I drew the first
came hot so when I was a piece down so I
felt why not continue yeah it's just I
can castle him and this is just I think
okay for me I thought actually I'm much
better but the computer points out this
weird move okay
yeah it's it's all tech tech Sam it's
all tactics I probably should have gone
to d3m me norm computer wants to play
book C Mon it's not a move I thought
about at all yeah yeah I probably play
that so great here to set the problem if
I cannot castle here I mean okay this is
entirely ridiculous and he can take care
of course am I mean that was it was
clear but he didn't see it or something
was not clicking there this is a matter
of course and yeah I don't have any
defense here that sits quite quite
convincing but of course I just appease
up and there were many ways white could
have could have won that go check it's
still winning here check in this also
but it gets tricky if you have 30
seconds on the clock you can easily
easily screw it up let's get shiny wait
finally went wrong yeah 93 after that
it's a it's a draw and King g6 check
running out of moves now yeah I'm very
lucky when and when I totally
overestimated the position here before i
blundered I really thought that my
position would be would be good here
because of the bishop pair and his size
somewhat awkward pawn structure it's got
their file he's got very active pieces
though which an estimated as bad mother
boom okay thanks for watching